según el tipo de cáncer que tenga su
médico podría recomendar braquiterapia
también llamada radioterapia interna
las células crecen y se dividen como
parte de su ciclo normal el núcleo
celular controla este proceso dentro del
núcleo hay material genético llamado adn
que contiene las instrucciones que
dirigen este proceso
a veces el adn se daña
normalmente el adn responde reparándose
u ordenando la muerte de la célula
con el cáncer sin embargo las partes del
adn celular que dirigen la división se
dañan
este daño impide que el adn se repare o
le ordene a la célula que muera
por el contrario el adn defectuoso hace
que la célula crezca y se divida
incontrolablemente creando células
cancerosas
un tumor se forma cuando las células
cancerosas se multiplican y desplazan a
las normales
la braquiterapia trate el cáncer en los
siguientes órganos mamas
y órganos del aparato digestivo como el
esófago
y el conducto biliar debajo de su hígado
órganos reproductivos femeninos como el
útero el cuello uterino
y la vagina
y la próstata en los hombres
el recto
y la piel
y la zona del cuello y la cabeza
y los pulmones
la braquiterapia es un tratamiento que
consiste en colocar material radiactivo
cerca del cáncer según el procedimiento
se colocarán alambres cintas o grano los
llamados semillas directamente en su
tumor o cerca de éste
y la radiación de la braquiterapia mata
las células cancerosas al dañar
abrumadoramente el adn de estas
el tumor se encoge porque las células
dejan de dividirse y mueren
hay dos tipos de braquiterapia temporal
y permanente si recibe braquiterapia
temporal su médico le insertará un
dispositivo de colocación como un
broncoscopio para acercarse al cáncer
todo lo posible la braquiterapia
temporal suele ser una fuente de
material radiactivo de dosis alta que
trata su cáncer por varios minutos
cuando termine el tratamiento la fuente
de radiación se extrae
si recibe braquiterapia permanente su
médico le implantará semillas
radiactivas que permanecerán en su
cuerpo y emitirán radiación continua en
dosis bajas
y las semillas se debilitarán con el
tiempo y gradualmente dejarán de emitir
radiación
la braquiterapia se puede usar junto con
radioterapia externa u otros
tratamientos para el cáncer
sin embargo las ventajas de la
braquiterapia sobre la radiación externa
incluyen una dosis de radiación más alta
y focalizada en menos tiempo
y menor exposición del tejido normal
cercano a la radiación